we'll keep taking call 617 830 for 750
who's on with me now are the bar from
Detroit all right you said you said this
is Bob from Detroit uh [ __ ] you Bob yeah
okay what's your question a buck but ok
uck look I got uh yeah uh David Lewis
Rachel and uh Jason I wanted to uh ask
uh when do I call in if I wanted to call
in my getting off or thursday or
wednesday or do a weekly to upload a
video and uh my other question about
what to do Lewis doing next cuz uh is it
the end of Lewis as we know it and
lastly can you bring in a durian fruit
for the last david patten show episode
can we bring a what I'm having a durian
durian fruit I see I'm having a heck of
a time hearing about called first of all
let me let me answer to this question
please so it's always wednesday at 115
p.m. eastern time to make phone calls in
or and and at first we started on
thursday we changed that so it should be
consistent from here on out i believe so
the foreseeable future uh number two I
have no idea what I'm going to do next
and uh I don't really have a plan and I
kinda like that I don't have a plan but
i'm just gonna be um just a wandering
soul for a little while as but to the
question asked by buck this is if you
yes this is the end of Louis as we know
it I mean you're going to continue to
exist in the universe right I will exist
yeah yeah in in whatever whatever vessel
i'm currently in right now but uh uh we
we don't have any plans for me to be
part of the show although i'd imagine
once in a while uh Dave might want to to
use me as some type of interview guests
right uh and as far as the durian fruit
I think it would be interesting we have
a few things planned for lewis's last
week but we didn't think about bringing
in a durian fruit but it's an idea you
know what there's there's this asian
market right near me and they sell whole
durians yeah and maybe we should do that
it's
it's an idea I like I like your thinking
but it will will gonna research will
begin to research the possibilities
thank you well in my three country this
morning science the confess it's really
really really pungent ya know that's
what ever it on the hotel them what not
well lord knows other others around your
house like a bar studio enough times we
can return the favor alright thanks very
much for the call but uh we will report
back about what we find thanks never
take you call enjoy the day gamefly is
sort of like Netflix for video games
they have over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can play as many games as you want for
one monthly fee and if you find some
games you want to keep you can buy them
for a low used price there's never any
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30 day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com /
tdps